can you tell us about anyone who's
injured and also it's far too early to
give you any numbers within this moment
i'm kinda cool man water is not what
Gina of the shooters good news i was
comfortable important than me i can't at
this point answer that question are we
cut exactly there are five people who
dared it's not like it's only a superior
to the ability that Wichita toward of
nama our priority is to catch the
attackers at this stage it's the most
angling for technical on gunsalus com
zero and then we will inform you again
no then you want to omit annum manalang
buffer that's just yes mad hungry isn't
in an iron coffin we first were alerted
when somebody entered the shopping
center with a weapon papas yet distinct
accuses correct attic news mehsoos among
these are slim symmetric anonymous again
when this is awkward sorta sort of an
Oscar gowns and we rushed to the scene
we're doing what we can in North whorfin
I didn't inverse of lovers the emergency
calls to us there's an armed man was
on-site suits on person Zia Zia phelan d
come naturally osteitis paper machine
our digital pod abolishing politicized
as well or the emergency service self
from Munich at the moment who was
attending at the scene musician alone
official organ is yeah but we are so
Tata for looking at backup from the
region also i can put its own